Moutstache Bob Stokey, walking along like
he’s in a cormac mccarthy novel.
Making himself a drunk hut.
Almost like he’s making himself a prison.
The montage has a nice song on it.
Why is he by himself though?
Daryl pulls up on a bike with Glenn.
This must be a flashback to when Bob first
found them.
Daryl asks him the three questions.
“It doesn’t matter who you are.”
Flash forward to the mist, bob, sasha, maggie.
Walkers sounds all around.
massing - best moment.
(smoke machine joke).
Maggie almost goes down just like beth.
Bob gets bit and seems like he’s lying about
it.
Daryl still teaching Beth to track, she’s
having fun now.
She’s turning into Arya Stark.
She steps on a trap and almost gets bit.
“Pretty soon I won’t need you anymore”.
Moment is good example of why she still does.
Maggie’s compass broken and fog everywhere.
They’re lost.
Daryl gives beth Piggy back ride.
They find another house.
They stop to put flowers on a grave.
“I don’t think the good ones survive”.
The grave was a father, makes her think about
Hershel.
Maggie etc find train tracks and Sanctuary
sign.
Terminus.
Bob stokey references the time in the car
they heard the message.
Sasha is mistrusful.
Daryl and beth find out it’s a funeral parlor.
Walker looks like it was prepped.
Beth wants to leave thank you note, daryl
suggests staying.
He’s getting nicer, Beth is rubbing off
on him.
She makes fun of his shrugging emotes.
They have a very awkward pause.
Walkers mass.
Daryl barely escapes.
The show is teasing us with dead or dying
characters.
Beth takes off in a car.
Whole lotta bob stokey and sasha.
He’s still bleeding from his wound.
They’re trying to catch maggie, who has
been leaving messages for Glenn using walker
blood.
Bob stokey sasha kiss doesn’t seem super
romantic.
She tells him “You don’t have to be alone
again.”
Bob is being really noble but he’s probably
going to die.
She finds maggie lying in a pile of bodies
after stokey takes off.
Daryl is running down the road.
Looks like he needs some exercise.
He finds the railroad tracks too.
Maggie finally calms the fuck down and asks
sasha for help and they head after bob stokey
and plan to head toward terminus.
Daryl sits down in a pile near the tracks
and runs into the people that found Rick.
They circle him and looks like he’s going
to die.
“Why hurt yourself when you can hurt other
people.”
- tells him his name’s joe.
Seems like they’re not going to kill him
then.
Bob back on his own again like in the beginning,
but maggie and beth find him.
and it seems all good.
Glenn touches terminus sign so seems like
everyone but rick’s group meeting up.
Back to carol’s group next.
Looks like the girls are in trouble.
Where did beth go?
What’s going to happen to bob.
Hey youtubers it’s charlie and this week
on Walking Dead death was just hanging over
everyone like a cloud.
The episode title was Alone and there were
a lot of teasers for Sanctuary as has been
the tradition since the show came back and
potential reunions.
There were also a few things that made me
re-evaluate who I think is going to end up
dying.
Quick shoutout to the Giveaway this week.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I just give away a gift card for each episode
of Walking Dead to say thank you to you guys
for being so awesome.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
I’ll be announcing the winner in my Q&A
video tomorrow.
So now let’s talk about our Top 5 WTF Moments
and then I’ll do my review.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Number 5 - Maggie Takes off looking for Glenn.
So as the title implies there was going to
be some separating in the episode and Maggie
and Beth had this weird sister mojo between
them where for some reason they were both
the ones to lose it and take off running.
Maggie of course not being one to waste resources
totally used the walkers as finger paints.
I have to say this wasn’t the biggest plot
point, but I laughed and threw up in my mouth
at the same time.
Maggie is so crazy, so much more crazy than
I think we realize.
Sasha had that great monologue where she talked
about getting warnings and only getting them
once.
Maggie kind of got hers, and even though she
realized she needed help I wonder what’s
going to happen in the next situation like
this.
I have a feeling Sasha won’t magically appear
to rescue her.
Number 4 - Beth Leaves Daryl in the dust.
WTF, this was one of my bigger fist shaking
moments.
We didn’t see her get in the car, but it’s
implied that she’s the one that took off.
Daryl on the other hand had that thing that
the governor had, where no matter how many
Walkers pile on you, they always crawl away
without a scratch.
Daryl isn’t invincible, but I’m sure the
theory will get tested even more.
Number 3 - Beth starts turning into Arya Stark.
I loved the opening scene with them so much,
but I always get frustrated when characters
that are clearly smart have slip and falls.
That’s what I’m calling Beth stepping
in the trap.
It’s like she can learn Daryl’s complex
bow but she can’t walk without falling down.
I blame the writers for things like that,
they’re trying to show us how Beth thinks
she’s better than she really is.
But I don’t see why she has to be a klutz
for us to understand that.
Putting that aside, I’ll say the big question
we need to answer is why did she tear off
in the car?
She must have either totally flipped or thought
that Daryl was dead.
I’m choosing to believe that she just got
scared and flipped out.
She and Daryl had just had those long monologues
about seeing the good in everything.
Even if the good ones are always destined
to die.
Number 2 - Bob Stokey gets bitten.
This could really go either way, but him getting
bit shot him to the top of my death list.
He’s an alcoholic and addicts tend to lie
a lot.
Mostly about drinking, but something tells
me that unless his wound gets treated in the
next episode, he’s only going to get worse
and turn in the middle of the night.
Hopefully he and Sasha aren’t sharing a
sleeping bag by that point.
The other big Bob thing that I noticed was
his Knight in shining armor routine.
He’s probably just been doing that because
of Sasha, but I like this Bob way better than
the one Daryl almost threw off a roof earlier
this season.
We all need to keep our eyes on him though.
Sometimes shows will build a weak character
up like this just so they can tear them down.
Bob just blew past Maggie on my list of people
who might die this season.
and my number 1 moment.
Daryl meets Joe and the psychopaths.
I’m choosing to think of them as a version
of the Hunters from the comic book.
We’ll have to see if they behave the same
way the comic book group does.
But Joe’s quote, why hurt yourself when
you can hurt others.
Doesn’t bode well.
This was another almost death scene.
Daryl just lying there in the road defeated.
I’m so glad that it wasn’t Beth there
instead.
As a bonus best moment I have to mention Glenn,
who is definitely going to see Maggie’s
Finger Paint signs and find them.
I love how those two think alike.
Glenn is definitely stubborn, but he’s not
as crazy as Maggie.
There was actually a recent fake wedding photo
of the two of them.
Which kind of makes me nervous that things
won’t end well.
So now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moment from the episode was.
The three big questions we need to answer
in the comments and in my Q&A tomorrow is
one, where did Beth go? two, what is going
to happen to Daryl?
and three, what is going to happen to Bob?
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, I did
an amazing job of just hanging the threat
of each person dying over our heads.
First Maggie gets pinned, then Daryl get’s
pinned, Bob gets full on bitten.
It doesn’t stop.
Sasha kind of has this foreboding moment as
they’re debating the Terminus and the music
cues make it seem like yes, The Terminus is
a bad place.
We don’t have that much farther to go before
the finale and at the pace each group is moving
I wonder if that finale named “A” really
means Alexandria.
Washington is not that close and if anyone
is going to get there, it’s going to take
a full tank of gas.
Beth did just jump in the car, so maybe she’s
headed in that direction?
Let’s discussify in the comments and be
sure to subscribe to get that Q&A tomorrow.
We’re probably only a week or two away from
one of the groups reaching the Terminus.
Right now click here for that Q&A and click
here for the new Game of Thrones Trailer that
just posted.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!